so we had some friends over and their
whole people like me I mean in their
late 50s early 60s that kind of thing
and we were all sitting around talking
we said what are some things that we
miss that are no longer made from our
childhood items and there are some funny
things that came up but one of the guys
piped up and said I miss having a car I
can work on you see in our era we could
turn orange
I changed the engine out in my car
change the transmission out in my car's
certainly change the spark plugs set the
timing with an old thing called a
distributor cap that you don't have
anymore
all these kinds of things and you know I
kind of miss it I kind of don't miss it
I like to having cars I don't work on
right thank goodness we financially
graduated to that point but there was
something uniquely do-it-yourself about
if your car broke you can fix it the
battery went out on my wife's car the
other day I couldn't even get the stuff
off from around it partly to get the bat
to get to it to try to charge it and
then when I did the computer all shut
down and you know you had to reboot the
car as I he's out of my league now so
one of the things I like her I like cars
so I I just bought a 1960 because I was
born in 1960 classic Corvette one of the
benefits of that that I didn't think
about is is that I can actually work on
it the other day I had a little trouble
getting it started and I do exactly what
to do to tinker on it to get that engine
running it's kind of fun that's a great
car I mean it's a hotrod it's been
rebuilt the suspensions not much those
old suspensions weren't very tight now
I've also got I'm a Corvette guy I've
also got a new Corvette
now the chances of me being able to
touch that new Corvette under that
engine zero
couldn't help anything if it was broken
I'd be done I'm completely done I'll
hire someone else to work on something I
don't know how to do doing your taxes
exactly the same way back in the old
days I don't know
taxes were simple use your life was
simple it's not simple now and there's
nothing simple no matter how simple your
life is about your taxes and to doing it
yourself on your taxes is like me trying
to work on that new Corvette now I
understand the mentality because I've
got the old one and I enjoy that idea
but I don't do my own taxes anymore and
I don't work on my own cars anymore now
is that because I'm some rich guy no
it's because I've learned to hire
someone to do work I don't know how to
do it's done more efficiently I don't
break things it saves me money the
average person using software spends 791
dollars more on their income tax bill
than the average person using an income
tax professional there you go
don't do it yourself it's like working
on one of these new cars I don't get
somebody else to do it and you save
money and you don't bust your knuckles
up